Muun muassa - Yle Areena.
(Musiikkia)
Näitä urheilijoita seuranneena minä olen kiinnittänyt semmoiseen asiaan huomioon, että kun nämä vanhemmat urheilijat sanotaan nyt Iivo Niskanen, tämmöset kaikki ja muut kun ne.
Häviää niin sitten se on ihan törkeetä kattoa niitten sen kielen käyttöä ja vaikka ne sitten pääsis maaliin niin ei vitti edes pyyhkästä räkää sitä nenän alta että roikkuu puoli metriä siinä ja sitten ei yhtään aatella mitä sanotaan ja puhutaan se on ihan ihan törkeetä mutta siinä on kauhea ero sitten kun on nämä nykyajan nuoret urheilijat niin niillä on sivistystä ja niillä on.
Ne osaa hienosti puhua, hymyllä, auraa ja kertoo tästä tuodituksesta mutta tämmönen puuttuu kaikki näiltä vanhemmilta. Ei minkään näköisiä käytöstapoja ole näillä. Tässä olisi vähän korjaamista. Ei mulla muuta. Morjas.
Kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinuora tässä tervehdyissä. Noista urheilijoista puheen ollen yksi tänne viikon varrella soittanut kritisoi sitä kun entiset urheilijat pyrkivät kansan edustajaksi. Sitä sellaista kritiikkiä satelee tämänkertaisessa jaksossa kyllä muidenkin päälle muun muassa Yhdysvaltojen, Venäjän ja täällä kotimaassa Postin. Posti ei suikaan ainoa asia tässä maassa josta löytyy korjattavaa kuten ihan hetken kuluttua kuullaan. Sitä ennen yksi vie.
Kokonaisesti saapunut meidän WhatsAppiin ja alkaa että kansanradion kuuntelijat. Lopettakaa ikuinen valittaminen koiran kakasta. Kakka maatuu luontoon mutta muovi- ja piparmintuiset nikotiinipussit eivät. Pentukoirani on ehtinyt jo maistelemaan nikotiinipusseja. Nikotiinahan on koiralle myrkkyä. P.S. Korjaan kyllä oman koirani jätökset. Kosku tässä soittelee Helsingistä. On ruvennut käymään koirua tommana sama kuin maanainen.
Urheilukilpailussa on se varmaan vanhan sana mutta maanmies on olevassa ja miksei sitä voi käyttää sukupuolesta riippumatta koska se on sukupuoleton. En tiedä sitten onko tosiaan vaan Minukor vain käynyt tämä sana vai onko se lyöinen käytäntö nykyään. En tiedä sitten eipä tässä muuta.
maksamatta. Kolmen euron lasku oli ollut viime vuoden puolella ja ei ollut koskaan sitä nähnyt. No sitten tuli viiden euron muistuslasku ja tälle päivälle sitten kahdeksan euroa maksettavaksi.
No minäpä sitten soitin tähän vakuutusyhtiöltään, olen sille nuorelle kaverille, että eikö teillä yhtään ole peliselimää? Ja tällä tavalla ilmoitetaan asioista, ettei anna kyllä kovin hyvää kuvaa. En ole koskaan törmännyt tällaiseen, että kolmen euron laskua karhotaan, jossa on vahingossa jäänyt maksamatta. Se tulee myöhään ja siihen tulee vielä viiden euron muistuslasku. No ei siinä mitään kahdeksan euroa, ei siinä mitään maksoon sen kiltisti sitten kuitenkin.
Mutta täytyy sanoa, että pitäisikö itkiä vai nauraa? Hei. No terve vaan, kevät koittaa. Mietin tässä näin, kuinka paljon taas kuolee liikenteessä sähköpotkulautailijoita ja polkupyöräilijoita, kun nuo liikennesäännöt on aika epäselvät. Mä itse ajan tässä seitkytviisituhat kilometri vuodessa henkilöauton kanssa ja mä aina joudun palaamaan uudestaan niihin sääntöihin ja miettimään miten ne menee.
En tiedä kuka voisi valistaa fiksusti nuorille ja autoilijoille ja kaikille, että miten nyt menee nämä pyöräilijöitten väistämissäännöt. Ne ovat minun mielestäni niin monimutkaiset, vaikkei ne varmaan olekaan, mutta siellä puolella varmaan olisi paljon tehtävää, niin voitaisiin säästää monta henkeä. Vai mitä otte mieltä?
voi turskan perkeet, että ottaa kuule patti. Nämä eläkeyhtiöt kun ei ole lopettanut sen vuosikirjeen lähettämiseen. Mistä sinä tarkastat verotuksen, että sinä saa minkäänlaista paperia eläkeyhtiöltä? Ja siinä paperissa on myös se, että paljonko eläke nousee. Lähettäkään ne vuosikirjeet ilman erillistä soittoa, kun sinne ei tahdo päästä.
eläkeyhtiöille kun yrittää soittaa niin kasketaan vain painaa tuoteja tätä ja sitten kun on niitä tehnyt niin sitten sanotaan että sinä voit tässä semmoista asiaa hoitaakaan ja aivan kauhiaan kallistaan soittaa sinne että aika näyttää sano akuankka. Heippa!
Tää ei ole mikään uusi ilmiö tää poliisi väkivalta mutta ei ole tää muuta. Tää ei ole mikään uusi ilmiö tää poliisi väkivalta mutta ei ole tää muuta.
Kaikki jaoheitaan yksinkin mutta vähän on niin jaoheitaan sitä jaoheliaks. Ei keittolihaakaan? Ei. Keksitääkö me sitten joku joku joku korvaava? No tuota kyllähän vielä voi kana keittoo kehittää mutta tuota niin jos tätä menoa jatkuu niin ei ole kohta kana lihaakaan eihän se tuota mavenilijat ei myy takaas ottaa tuota niin kohta lihoja ettei meillä ole kohta mitään lihaa sitten. Sitä ruvetaan tuomaan sitten ulkomailta. Niin ja se ei ole sellainen kehitys mitä mitä.
No ei siis tää ei tiedä mitä sieltä saa. Se pitää varmaan herätä tähän asiaan nyt ennen kuin on myöhäistä ilmavenilijat kasvata tuota niin elvokoita jos ne saa siitä korvausta. No se on kyllä hyvin totta kun nyt vie jo noita vasikoita tuonne ulkomailte. Eli kenen pitäisi tähän herätä sitten? No kai se tuota niin NTK:n tai kun se kauppia vetää välistään niin kuin mavenilijat eivät saa rahaa.
Joo tässä alkaa eli tulee pian keittoa ikävä kun ei keittoa ainaksiaan saa. Niin joo no sitten ei syös ensi jonna kohta ei syö karjala paistia kaikkien lihan menee siihen jaoi lihaa. Hei mutta joo hyvä kun soitit tänne. Joo kiitti. Minä kiitän kanssa kiitos paljon. Moi. Hei.
suomisellani oli silmin näkijöitä, mutta kukaan ei vaivautunut kysymään, että miten kävi. Yksi rouva jäi vain tuijottamaan minua ja käveli sitten kohti kauppaa. Jokaisen velvollisuus on auttaa toisia hätätilanteessa, mutta tämä sääntö ei näköjään päde ihan kaikkiin. Tuntuu pahalta ajatella, että sen kerran kun itse tarvitsen apua, niin kukaan ei auta. Itse aina pyrin auttamaan toisia hädän hetkellä, tunsin sitten avun tarvitsevaa tai en. Hyvä kevään odotusta
Kansanradion kuuntelijoille. Muistakaa liikkua varovasti ja auttaa toisia tarpeen tullen, tällaisen viestin laittanut Kuopion tyttö.
Seuraavakin puhelu on osoitettu meille kaikille. Sitä seuraavat puhelut puolestaan heille, joilla on hieman keskivertokansalaista enemmän päätäntävaltaa.
Kansanradio. Se on Veikko Kukkonen päivää. Veikko Kukkonen vanha kuoma. Mitä kuuluu? No ihan hyvää kevättä tullee ja se on nimittäin teeriö aloittaneen jolla on kevätsoitimen ja se on varma kevään merkki. Kvetto aloittelee sitten kun tullee pelehpiä. Aivan mahtavaa alokaa mielivirkistymään niin. Ihan asiaa tuota kun nyt eduskuntavaaleihin on reilu vuosi niin minä kyllä kansalaisen miettisin että ei se kannata äänestää yhtään.
Niissä on tuo entistä urheilija tai joka vielä urheilija. Se hakkee suojatyöpaikkaa. Ei hänen urheilumeriteellä ole mitään tekemistä sinne eduskunnassa. Meillä on niin suomalaisen kuuluisia esimerkkejä näistä urheilijoista. Ei silti ole sillä kaiken maan muistakin viisun likkarista ja laulun tekijöistä ja semmoisista. Ainut joka minun mielestä nyt on näistä entistä urheilijoista Sami Multala on osoittanut pätevyytensä. Hänhän oli mikä alan ministeri se olikaan tuota nuilli.
Mutta eikös tuo nyt sitten tarkoita että se voikin olla että urheilija on pätevä poliitikko jos kerta Sari Multalakin.
Niin ja kannattaa sitä vähän kuunnella että mitä itse kukin ehdokas sitten on minkälaista asiaa ajamassa. Siis joo tämä asti kun alkaa tämä vaalihäditeli taas alkaa pitoa noin niin jokainen kantailee näitä kylitteitä tarvukuutta ja toimikykyinen eduskunta ja kaikkihan luottaa. Ei yksinään ehdokas edustaja voi luota yhtään mitään. Se on puoluekuri jonka mukaan toimitaan tehdään tuota noin ja se on ihan turha että minua äänestämällä. Se on ihan semmoista.
Turhaa mutta kai se on tuo tyyli että sitä pitää tuolla tulla näkyä kumminkin ja koettaa tuo esille itse että minä en mene turhaan laapaan koskaan. Minä sen verran perinnä politiikassa tuota jopa alan kantaakin näihin asioihin ja kansanedustajien kanssa vähän sähköpostia ja niin edelleen.
Eli siis toisin sanottuna Veikkoa ei huijata. - Kyllä nimenomaan Veikkoa ei huijata. Mä toin tässä pieni Tirsan nokka unet huokailemaan. Lähden sitten käymään meillä tässä pyöräille tai käveleen lähden. Jo meni sen verran myöhään ilalla kun tulin kotia että yöhun ei ehkä ollut ihan riittävää niin ihan pikkusen viihteellä. Hyvin vähän. - Kyllä pitää välillä viihteelläkin käydä mutta... - Aakkohan soitat tuota nuijaa. Tässähän on tää kun on kesätanssilla vaan kauppaa.
ja laakaanpiton. - No niin, mainitaan. - No ei muuta. - Joo, toivotetaan päivän jatkut. - Samoin sinulle. - Jes, kiitos Mummo.
- Kuntelin tuossa ties monennen kuin kerran näitä kansanrannia tai tää älyskunnan puhemiesten juttuja ja joskus tulee mieleen että onkohan nämä toisintoja niistä vanhoista, koska nämä jauhaa ihan samoja asioita. Vähennetään, vähennetään, kuluja vuistetaan.
Budjettia pienennetään. En ole mitään kuullut siitä millä niillä lisätään työpaikkoja, firmoja, firmojen kannattavuutta. Siellä on tieto niistäkin, mutta se ei ole eduskunnalla. Se täytyy olla siellä ulkopuolisilla osaajilla. Vankaa se kuntoon niin tää paskajauhminen loppuu siihen. Morjes.
No niin, hyvää päivää kansanradio ja siellä on se sitä sotea ja sotea nyt sitten voidaan selkkomaan niin mihin ulohtu tämä perusterveydenhuolto? Että kun minäkään en ole vielä mennyt Kelaankaan mihinkään, mutta tuota jos se perusterveydenhuolto pelais, että sinne pääsis kertomaan huolesa silloin kun tulee työpaikkoja.
Nyt kun on tarvetta niin siitä voitais säästyä paljolta, mutta kun tota noin niin tää näyttää nyt siltä, että jos hivahtaa kauan terveyskeskuksen tai johonkin niin lasku tulee heti. Eihän tää onko ne eläke mikä minulla on niin siis jos mä nyt sairastun niin minun menen nämä eläketulot siihen. Mutta jos olisi perusterveydenhuolto et voisi kertoa jo heti että nyt vaivuu tasta tai vaivaa tasta.
Silloin säästetään hirveän paljon näitä sairaudenhoitokuluja, että semmoinen uutiselimotus eteenpäin, että pärjäällään ja kaikille hyvää. Kiitos. Voin vielä sanoa, että tämä oli tuula. Kiitos.
No vanhempi mies tästä laadun seudulta. Kansanedustajat ja ministerit kyselytunnella tuisottaavat pelkästään tietokoneita ja kännyköitä ja sitten koululaisilta he kieltävät kuitenkin kännyköitten käytön koulussa. Kansanedustajat ja ministerit saavat palkkaa sen tunnin lähetyksessä mikä televisioita näyttää ja kuka ei kuuntele toistensa puheita ollenkaan, että ollaan hyvin pöttynyt eduskunnan toimintaan ja ei muuta. Kiitti.
Hyvää huomenta Kansanradion nauhat. Tässä kuuntelin erään sosialidemokraattinaisen juttua tuolta Ammu radiosta ja minun pitää sanoa, että minä en pysty sitä kuuntelemaan kuin hetken ja sen jälkeen painan nappia. Tämä sammuu ääni sieltä radiosta. On niin kovaa jäkätystä, että ei voi käsittää.
Ei kerta kaikkiaan voi käsittää eikä ymmärrä. Kiitos. Hei. - Meille yksi saapunut kirje alkaa että moro. Ihan turhaa parran ...
pärinää taas Suomen autojen vaikutuksesta ilmastonmuutokseen kun puuttiin Trump ynnä muut vähät välittävät ja nykypoliitikkojen nokittelu ...
idän suuntaan on vaan tullut meille kalliiksi Nato, Ukraina, Kaapelivauriot, Yms ja sitten se ilmastonmuutos. Voisiko välillä rahastaa sitä lentomatkailua myös? Esimerkiksi porttimaksu kaksisataa euroa per kerta. Se kohdistuisi paremmin tasaveroja kannattaviin kun se ei ole kuitenkaan aina niin välttämätöntä. Tasapalkkaa kannattavaa laittanut tällaisen viestin p.s. olen vuosikymmeniä harrastanut nojatuolimatkailua.
Kotimaan asioita tässä on käsitelty nyt niin paljon, että vietetään ihan pieni tovi siellä ulkomailla kunnes sitten taas takaisin tänne kotisuomeen.
Sen minä tiedän, että suomalaiset ovat niin tyymiä, että ne äänestävät aina oppositiossa olevaa puoluetta neljän vuoden välein, mutta että ruotsalaisetkin ovat niin pöljiä. Jengit ovat toisiksi pöljimpiä. Niillä on sentäs kaksivaihtoehto ja ne äänestävät sitä hullua siellä. Nenäläiset ovat näistä neljästä viisampia. Ne äänestävät vain Putinia sen takia, että ne pysyisivät hengissä.
Tämmöistä minä ajattelin. Kyllä tyymys on levinnyt Ruotsiin asti. Veippa!
Puuhaat. Nämä suomalaiset elokuvat pitäisi suurimmalla osalla lailla kieltää ja siirtyä amerikkalaisiin ja englantilaisiin elokuviin ja musiikkinäytelmiin, koska nämä suomalaiset elokuvat ja musiikki ovat aivan hanurista. Pitäisi nostaa kunnian tämä Puuhaa Innasen sanotukset. Ne lähentävät niin minun syystä ja työstä.
Sydäntäniä, sydäntäniääniä ja sillä lailla ja tällä lailla. Ja tässä on minun sanoma. Ei muuta. Ellu rei.
Kunnassamasti kun tyhjää valitetaan. Jos ihminen on terve, niin ei ole mitään valittavista. Terveys on kaikista tärkein ja ystävät ja perhe. Terveys, ystävät ja perhe. Niin ja ainoa mikä minua nyt surettaa on se, että soditaan. No niin minä uskon, että siinäpä sellainen suru, jonka jakaa lähes, jonka jaat lähes kaikkien kanssa. Niin minulla on seitsemän lapsen lasta ja minä surein niitten puoleen.
Että niiden puoleen huolestaan, että ne joutuu elämään tämmöisessä maailmassa. Niin tulevakin vää huolestuttaa. Niin se huolestuttaa kovasti. Ja minä olen sitä mieltä, että tuommoisiin tärkeisiin virkoihin, niin kuin presidentin virkaan, kansanedustajan virkaan pitäisi tehdä laajat psykologiset testit ennen kuin niitä päästetään sinne. Niin kuin tämä Amerikan presidenttikin voi sanoa, että se on minun mielestä täysi tollo.
Niin ja samaten on tuopuuttin täysi tollo ja arvaamattomia molemmat. Ja muistakaa ihmiset ja vanhuksetkin olla kiitollisia, jos te pystytte elämään semmoista tervettää elämää, ettei tä nyt koko ajan tarvitse syöä kourakaupalla lääkkeitä ja pelätä, että nyt minä kuolen.
Niin se on sitten tämä, että ihminen joskus pitää asiaa itsestäänselvyytenä eikä tajua nauttia sitä ennen kuin sitä ollaan viemässä pois. No se on juuri niin, että sinä et tajua asiaa ennen kuin sinulta ollaan viemässä pois. Niin just nyt oli paljon asiaa. Muistetaan muistetaan arvostaa niitä asioita, joita meillä on. Ja sitten vähän huolta aiheuttaa se, että mihin tahansa ilmansuuntaan Suomesta katsoo, niin tolloja on siellä johtamassa maata. Niin juuri. Niin. Niin.
Niin ja pitää tosissaan tehdä niin kuin tuota psykologiset testit, ketkä pääsee näin suuren vallan kahvahan. Niin tällä tavalla me saattaisi maailman rauhaa, jos olisi terve järkisiä. Puolueettomat psykiatrit paikalle. Niin. Tutkimatta onko tällä niin kuin järkikähän päässyt. Ja kaikille toivon terve, että enkä toivo kenellekään, mitä sairaus tehneet. Sairastiminen tosi kurjaa.
- Isot kiitokset kun soitit. - Kiitoksia teille. - Ja mahdollisimman hyvät päivänjatkot kanssa. - Kiitoksia. - No se on kyllä erittäin hyvä muistutus tuo. Tietysti ihmisen hyvä muistaa myös se, että jos joku kiroaa huonosti nukutun yön jälkeen myöhässä olevaa bussia, niin eihän se henkilö siinä sitä arvota maailman isoimmaksi ongelmaksi. Se nyt vaan sillä hetkellä aiheuttaa sellaisen nopean harmituspiikin. Mutta kuten sanoin, hyvä muistutus tuo.
kommenttia seuraavaksi kunhan olen lukenut tämän postin tänne perille -kuljettaman kirjen jonka sisältö ei välttämättä postiin liity.
Hyvä kansanradio hävetkää lakkoilijat olisitte hyvillä ne että teillä on vielä työpaikat allella odottakaa parempaa suhdannetta Suomessa ja vaatikaa sitten korotusta.
Jos ei työ maistu ottakaa lopputili kyllä tulijoita on joille kelpaa pienempikin palkka. Mistä työnantajan yhteisee teille korotusta jostakin on säästettävä. Lopputili ja lomarahat osaa teitä odottaa että lakkoilkaa siihen nähden. Nimimerkki ei ne suuret tulot vaan pienet menot. Kiittää kirjensa lopuksi.
Minä olen pyytänyt että minulle tuotaisiin posti kotiovelle mutta kun soitan postin asiakaspalveluun niin siellä aina vastataan että olemme yrittäneet ottaa teihin yhteyttä mutta minuun ei ole yritetty ottaa yhteyttä.
Jos olisi otettu yhteyttä niin näkisinhän minä sen puhelin logitiedostoista. Tää on ihan täyttä kakkaa tää postinhommaa. Moi!
Minä olen nyt kahden kuukauden sisällä vastaan ottanut kolme pakettia joissa on särkyvät leimat ja ne näkyvät ihan pieltä päin että niitä on potkittu. Ja itse pitkällä kokemuksella voin sanoa että jos laittaa särkyvät leimat varsinkin postin pakettiin niin sen ne särkyvät tälle voisivat tehdä jotta viimeksi tuli matkahuollolta. Nyt on kaksi pakettia tullut kahden viikon sisään särkylienne ja ne sanovat siinä että tuli.
Ja nämä tulivat maahan jo särkyneenä että ei ollut matkahuollon vika mutta kai näitä on näitä paketin potkijoita monissa maissa ulkomaillakin kuljetusketkus jossa mutta herjää vaan kysymys mitä varten? Kuka tästä sopii illoin että särkee tuosten paketti että semmoinen kysymys oli minulla mielessä.
Ei tässä ole Pirjo. Onko tämä sota? Tulko siihen muna jatkea. Moi moi.
Ei tässä sitte muuta. Moi.
Ei mukaan olekaan päteviä vaikka he ovat ihan samalla lailla päteviä. Ei mulla muuta. Ihmettoulua.
Lyhenee velka. Se on aika kummallinen juttu. Miettikääpä itsekin, jos te maksat sitten velkaa jollekin ja se ei lyhene ja aina vaan kurjistetaan, niin eikö se ole vähän kova tilanne? Niin kuin yksityisestikin. Se on sitten valtion vallan taholta. Ja Orpukin vaan puhuu koko ajan sitä, että sata tuotta työpaikkaa vielä tulee ja kansausko. Se on kyllä kumma juttu. Politiikot valehtelevat niin paljon kuin on kerkeää. Niin kuin Putin, Trumpi, kaikki nämä.
suuret, niin kuin orpukin yrittää olla suuri, ja kansa uskoo. Milloin Suomen kansa herää, että ei se ole totta. Se on paha univa.
- Nimimerkki H. Hetki. Hallitus on esittänyt tai aikoo tehdä Suomesta ydinasevallan, että tänne voidaan tuoda esimerkiksi amerikkalaisia ydinaseita. En kannata tämmöstä.
- No enempää tästä, mutta tärkeämpää vielä olisi minusta nyt heti ryhtyä toimiin, että Suomen esimerkiksi väestönsuojat, pommisuojat ja nämä otetaan myös päivitykseen. Ne tilat pitää nyt saattaa semmoiseksi, että ne on valmiina ja nimenomaan niiden oikealta käyttötarkoitusta varten siviiliväestönsuojaaminen.
Ja kysynpä tässä, että paljonko Suomessa muuten on väestönsuojaa, vanhanaikaisesti sanottuna pommisuojaa, joka on esimerkiksi ydinaseen kestävä. Onko meillä ollenkaan semmoista sillä lailla? Hei hei.
Sähköpostia jos haluaa lähettää tänne, niin se on kansan.radio.yle.fi. Perinteistä postia siihen kuoreen kannattaa kirjoittaa, että kansanradio pl79 00024 Yleisradio ja meidän vastaaja 0800 15464.
Kyllä nyt voi sanoa jo, että perinteiseen malliin lähetyksen jälkeen kolmen tunnin ajan paikalla on ihmisvastaja. Lasse Olkinuora toivottaa mahdollisimman hyvää päivän jatkoa ja kaikista mahdollisista epäkohdista huolimatta hieman saa hymyilemään. Ainakin minut se kun kuulee tuolla Mustarastaan laulavan kovan äänen, että kevät saapuu. Tai voi olla, että Mustarastas laulaa kovan äänen. Sitä kuinka tämä on minun reviiri ja hei olisiko halukkaita puolisoita tulemaan tänne.
Joka tapauksessa siitä tulee ihmiselle hyvä mieli. Minä toivotan hyvää vointia. - Hyvää huomenta. En ymmärrä minkä takia Suomi on tämmöinen lälläreiden maa. Kantelijoiden maa ei kritiikkiä kestä. Koululaiset ei kakarat ei muuta. Sehän on mikä on vapaa kasvatus kun te olette semmoisen saaneet aikaiseksi. Kannellaan kaikesta ei kestetä yhtään mitään.
Sanomista ei kestetä. Tukkapölly ei kestetä. Mitään ei kestetä. Ei ole mikään ihme, että kaikki ovat vähän mieliterveysvikaisia Suomessa. Jos ei tämä penttisen tyyli, että sanotaan suoraan mikä on tilanne, jollet osaa luistella, jollet kestä. Ei. Men pois. Men muuhun seuraa. Turhassa siellä määrit ja kantelet ja muuta mökötät.
Hyvää päivänjatkoa. Veikkauksesta ja Veikkauksen voittorahojen käynnistä. Minkä ne rahat oikein menevät? Kun vähän osaisat ihmiset puutteessa ja köyhyydessä eläkellä ja sitten vähän jos on huonot tulot, niin ne yrittävät saada vähän käyttörahaa Veikkauksen kautta, niin se tulee juuri paljon yhtään mitään kuin pikku rippeitä. Rahat jäätään tuommoisen urheiluryhmille erilaiseen urheilun jääkiekkoon, jolle on jo hirveät tulot muutenkin ja monenlaiseen muuhun urheiluun.
Semmoiseen, mikä ei ole enemmän kunto urheilua jonkin verran olla, mutta kun se mennään tuommoiseen mielittömään ristiviitaseen tappailuihin, niin kun monta kertaa porukka tappelee keskenään siellä ja riitelee työniivät ja purjevat toisiinsa huonoon kuntoon, niin veikkajat eivät saa paljon kuin pikku rippeitä. Äärimmäisen harva saa koskaan täysosuvaa. Se on hirvittävän vahinko, jos se lukisopimus tulee. Tässä on tehtävä muutos. Reheellinen muutos oikeaan suuntaan. - Tässä.
Työtön tuumaa jo vaan tuumii tätä nykymeininkiä, että hyvät Arkadianmäen päättäjät, ottakaa nyt pyhät pyssykät ihmeessä se karvalakki pois silmiltä ja tehkää niin kuin pitää tehdä.
Elikkä veli Venäjä on aivan rohistovaltio ja nämä kaikki kiinteistöt mitä on Suomessa ehdottomasti pitää ratsata koska veli Venäläisellä on ollut porkkalan luovuttamisesta asti sellaiset mahdollisuudet kartottaa kaikki Suomen strategiset systeemit ja muut.
Niin nyt viimeistään Petterit ja kaikki tehkää se mikä teidän pitää tehdä. Kiitos näkemiin.
Kuinka paljon kommunistit johtaa? Kuinka paljon vihreät johtaa? Siis minä väitän että me suomalaiset olimme miehiä, naisia, poikia tai tyttös. Me emme ole niin pöljiä mitä vasemmistoliit ja kommunistit luulevat. Me olemme paljon viisampia kuin mitä te siellä jatkuvasti huuatte. Sata kertaa päivässä minä laskin yhtenä veen oli kuusikymmentä kolme kertaa muutaman tunnin siellä.
Demarit johtaa, demarit johtaa, demarit johtaa. Menkää Venäjälle temarit. Helvetin huutojat. Koko televisio pitäisi lopettaa jopa katottasti ostettaisiin muualta vaikka Englannista tai Ranskasta ohjelma. Minä sanon sen suoraan että minua inhoittaa tämä paskan jauhaminen kommunisti demarit. Menkää Venäjälle tai Kiinaan. Hyi kauhea mutta kiitos Kansanradiolle että on vielä yksi ohjelma johon voi olla puoluetumasti soittaa. Minusta ei ikinä tule kommunistia eikä tyhjää.
Eikä demaria. Ei ikinä. Minulle maatalonpojaksi syntynyt ja maatalonpoikana puolun. Kiitoksia.